saludos hemos trabajado mucho con
vectores como en el movimiento de
proyectiles o cuando resolvimos
problemas de plano inclinado les
mostraba un vector como éste con una
magnitud y un ángulo que después
descomponemos en sus componentes xy
entonces si este es el rector ve huella
más leve el índico como vector con esta
flechita encima
entonces su componente en x
y lo voy a dibujar en otro color
esta parte
su componente mx que es be subíndice x
como vector
y su
componentes
esta vez subíndice y como vector
entonces teníamos que
este vector ve en su componente x y yo
espero que a esta altura ya sea muy
natural para ustedes resolver este tipo
de problemas si queremos calcular su
vector x vamos a ver que esto es igual a
la magnitud 10 por el coseno del ángulo
de 30 grados si esto se les dificulta
les recomiendo que revisen los primeros
vídeos que vimos sobre vectores y sus
funciones trigonométricas ya que esto
viene de que queremos calcular esta
parte de este triángulo y es el cateto
perdón line el cateto adyacente entre la
hipotenusa y eso es 'la cocina'
y también bueno de la misma manera
resolvemos que este componente en llega
en mi vector b es igual a 10 seno de 30
grados
pero lo que quiero que hagamos ahora es
ver otra forma de trabajar con vectores
pues esto no será útil para problema no
para esto nos fue útil para problemas
sencillos de vectores como los vimos en
los primeros vídeos pero
cuando tenemos que resolver problemas
más complicados de proyectiles
trabajando con vectores
multidimensionales o trabajando con
álgebra lineal con factores de n
dimensiones entonces necesitaremos de
una manera coherente una manera
analítica para resolverlo en lugar de
tener siempre que está dibujando los
vectores y descomponer esos componentes
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es usar la
anotación de unidades vectoriales qué
significa esto
para definir estas unidades de vectores
permíteme dibujar un par de ejes ejes
coordenadas
tenemos aquí
este eje
y tenemos este otro
este es mi eje x este es mi eje y aquí
tengo
algunas medidas este punto es cero el
origen de mí me he coordinado
este es uno estos dos días en jet
también tengo exactamente en la misma
distribución 1 2
bueno voy a tener un vector llamado i
que va desde el origen hasta la primera
unidad en mi eje x y lo llamo y le
indicó que es un vector porque tiene
este como capuchinos o este sombrerito
encima
este rector y no tiene componente en eje
y y tiene una magnitud de 1
normalmente se denota o se define con
esta letra y con el capuchón pero hay
otras notaciones que tampoco usan esto
normalmente cuando ustedes ustedes vean
esta letra y siempre y cuando no sea un
contexto de números imaginarios o
complejos está y va a denotar que se
trata de el vector
unidad de vector en el eje x y ahora
también tenemos otro vector
que este va en la dirección del eje
de magnitud 1 y se denota por la letra j
también con un capuchón este vector no
tiene componentes x
y bueno para qué nos sirve esto bueno
veremos que podemos definir cualquier
vector en términos de la suma de estos
dos vectores como funciona bueno este
vector b va a ser la suma de los
vectores vx y b y entonces mi vector b
va a ser igual a mi compone a su
componente x
más su componente en jet
y podemos determinar o definir estos
vectores bx y ver cómo múltiplos de
estos vectores unitarios o estas
unidades de vector y j al menos si es en
dos dimensiones aunque podemos definir
también en varias dimensiones
así que
podemos definir esta mismo vector ven
bueno tenemos que ver el componente en x
es igual a 10 coseno de 30 esto es igual
a 10 por raíz de 3 entre 2 es igual a 5
por raíz de 3
esto es un múltiplo o si es un es un
múltiplo de este vector y que de una
unidad entonces nuestro vector b es
igual a este componente en x que es 5
raíz de tres veces el vector y
más el componente engine que es igual a
10 seno de 30 es un medio es igual a 5
entonces es igual a 5 raíz de 3 y más
cinco veces el vector unitario o unidad
j
y así estamos definiendo estamos
mostrando este vector cuál es la ventaja
bueno que yo puedo definir un vector en
estos términos analíticos y no necesito
hacer el dibujo para poder mostrar sus
componentes gráficamente
entonces vamos
y usar un ejemplo
que al menos en este ejemplo bueno es
algo muy sencillo que ya hemos resuelto
pero si estamos trabajando con suma o
resta o alguna operación más complicada
de vectores entonces el hacerlo
gráficamente ya no nos es práctico por
ejemplo si yo tuviera que sumar si yo
tengo por ejemplo con los vectores
bueno el vector va a ser igual a 2 y dos
veces el vector unitario y más 3
j y además tengo mi vector b que es
igual a 10 y
+ 2 j
la suma si yo quiero saber la suma de
estos dos vectores a más ven en el
método antiguo hubiera tenido que
dibujar estos dos vectores algo así
inventando esto no es obviamente no son
los vectores correctos pero hoy ha
tenido que dibujar un vector si éste
hubiera sido ah y luego en el donde
termina este iniciar el siguiente vector
por ejemplo si éste hubiera sido el
doctor b aunque no corresponden con
estas magnitudes y la suma hubiera
tenido que dibujar un vector desde el
inicio hasta el final de estos dos y
este vector sería a más de ellos hubiera
tenido que ser gráficamente estos
cálculos descomponer cada uno de sus
componentes xy
para hacer tener este resultado sin
embargo con esta anotación pues es mucho
más sencillo porque sólo necesito sumar
los componentes en 1 y aparte de los
componentes en jota y así obtengo mi
nuevo vector entonces tengo 10 más 2 y
+ 3 2
j
y tenemos 12 y las 5 j y así tenemos
nuestra suma a nuestro vector suma de
estos dos que es mucho más sencillo
y de hecho algo que ustedes quisieran
tal vez quisieran hacer es graficar
estos vectores y hacer la suma para que
vean que el resultado es exactamente
igual a este que acabamos de encontrar
conforme veamos futuros vídeos veremos
que esta anotación no se es
tremendamente útil para resolver
problemas más complicados de vectores
una vez que comencemos a ver física con
cálculo de cualquier manera ya estoy
llegando al límite de tiempo así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo